i mean sometimes when we disagree you're
so passionate i feel like i'm arguing
with the sun what that is totally crazy
i am super chill all the time
we did surgery just like you taught us
okay you know what why don't you girls
clean up all this hair and i'm gonna
talk to ron let's cut off our towel no
let's not i'm gonna take this bag too
you need to fix this
it's not that bad nobody got hurt it's
extremely bad
i love this woman and i just want to
show her that i'm capable of watching
her children without something horrible
happening
what
did you just say you love diane no
i did not yes you did that is so cute
for god's sake hansen will you please
focus on the larger problem
girls girls i don't know what you think
you heard but please don't tell your
mother what you incorrectly think you
heard
i love nothing
the hell am i supposed to sing it's time
andrew these kids are tearing my house
apart and i need you to calm them with
the power of song oh gosh here's the
thing i can't do it i got laryngitis you
will not bail on me andrew dwyer you
will perform my nephew with something
been outcast in his school and i got
erica sorvane to come which is a huge
get she rules the first grade and this
party will determine his social status
for the next 100 years so you better get
out there or i am going to lose that
have you not lost it well you don't even
know
what up perd big fan
me too perd
what up
the thing about this first question is
i'd like to ask you about the harvest
festival perd it's gonna be amazing
carnival rides games sweden is even
building a plus-size roller coaster for
some of pawnee's obese thrill-seekers
you must be this wide to ride wow that's
gonna be a pretty big roller coaster yep
hey guys how'd it go
well there were some sticky moments
let's go to the videotape
ah
look who hasn't had gay thoughts who are
you okay yeah i'm fine i'm fine i mean
you know sometimes i feel like i might
need glasses is there a bird in here i
swear i keep seeing a bird in the studio
maybe that's kind of what's happening to
it he was fine until bird started asking
about the boy mayor's stuff what's wrong
with you you look psychotic i was 18
when i was elected mayor okay so excuse
me for that cindy eckert had just turned
me down for senior prom do you know how
that feels i should call her i should i
no i shouldn't and i'm not going to and
i'm proud of myself for that so while
they repaint the lines in the parking
lot we're asking everyone to do street
parking i'm not street parking my
mercedes well everyone is i'm doing it
cause nobody wants to steal a saturn
all right uh moving on to recycling
you okay ron
just a little tooth pain i'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins
do you need to go to the dentist ron i
don't like dentists just a second
hey no no no no
[Applause]
oh my god i'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about recycling
dentist pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see tom faint
[Laughter]
greg pochitis
would you like some boiling hot coffee
your face
my name is bert macklin
yeah i'm with the
fbi
[Music]
huh looks like andy's wearing him down
i'm gonna go finish him off
that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard don't you just shut up for a
second what's going on
he's a jerk he's being such a jerk it's
an awful thing to say to a human being
are you crying no i'm i'm not crying
okay i'm allergic to jerks okay andy out
fine i don't care it's stupid
okay look i think um things are starting
to get a little out of control here i
agree you betrayed me and you went
behind my back and now you need to pay
i need to i need to pay do i stutter oh
okay fair enough oh you know what you
might want to borrow this no no one
wants your dirty underwear but it's not
dirty underwear it's a white flag and
you may as well start waving it right
now i will be waving is your decapitated
head on a stick in front of your weeping
mother
good lord oh my god oh my god
over here all right
get your hat around i have your hat oh
my god hey in a lot of pain i was shot
in the head with a shotgun ron it's
actually not that serious i just need
you to stay calm okay yeah i'm just
gonna stay angry i find that relaxes me
okay ron we called 9-1-1 and they're
gonna send a ranger oh damn this is a
mess the rangers won't let us come back
next year what we're not gonna think
about that right now you guys can you
just put him on the day bed in the
carcass room daybed yeah
sure
okay
donna
donna
[Applause]
are you okay
what is it your heart are you having
trouble breathing
hey okay how are you feeling how are you
feeling are you dizzy dizzy are you
light-headed when i look at my palm i
see a lady's mouth french kissing a dog
is that normal
well the pain medication i gave you is
pretty strong donna uses it for
menstrual cramps how many did you take
seven eight
better wash them down with plenty of
fluids no ron you cannot drink scotch
with this you're gonna need to purge
right now okay
oh
20 yeah can you open his mouth leslie
what open his mouth no open his mouth
okay i'm not making myself throw oh ryan
you're sorry we have to do this let's
run around good i will bite you roll in
your mouth listen grab this mustache
open your mouth
open your mouth
his shoulders
well good news is ron is resting
comfortably
happy anniversary
it's the iron throne oh
it's the iron throne yes it is i had a
guy at the model store make a replica
he's a bigger game of thrones fan than
you
are okay i know i'm making that dumb
surprise face but i can't help it this
is the greatest gift i've ever received
leslie
okay
honestly how do you think i'm doing
because i i feel like we're getting
along pretty well in love with me
what's that while you were in the
bathroom he said he was still in love
with me oh my god leslie he's a cop
he's in love with you and he has a gun
can you just not freak out i'm not
freaking out okay i'm not freaking uh
i know that's
i
know oh
it was raining out so i didn't want to
get wet
hey ann
what happened i just saw you a few hours
ago and you were fine not like
damn you're fine but fine health-wise
my body has no fat to protect itself
from disease things happen very quickly
listen to me it's very important that
you replenish my body with electrolytes
after every involuntary loss of bodily
fluids
my body tends to lose a lot
of fluids when it's sick
my brain is on fire i'm dying
well you definitely have the flu
oh my god
the microchip has been compromised
i vomited somewhere in this room
i don't remember where though
wait you might want to check that drawer
stop
pooping
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friends
you